Hi, it's uh. Solista Ronan Bonango here. Uh.
Thank you all and welcome again uh.
To the breaking news concerning the changes
which were announced on December 4th, 2023 by uh.
Home secretary, uh.
James Cleverly.
Uh. The statement of uh.
Change. Change date to 7th of December
has now confirmed and has announced today uh.
That the check proposed changes uh.
Would take if
would take effect in the spring of 2020. 4 uh.
Will not affect those
lodging applications for extensions I they.
They definitely to remain or uh.
New applications made by those who are already here uh.
Uh. Uh. For their dependence.
The policy is uh.
Said to be forward looking and not backward facing. Uh.
There it will a.
There'll be an exemption uh.
Under what is known as transitional arrangements, uh.
Which has been confirmed.
Uh. I just to reiterate,
the changes will be those
that affects the social care workers um.
Who will be allowed to bring the dependence uh.
Changes to the shortage occupation list uh.
Significantly.
Which reduces the number of jobs where.
Which were uh.
Where. Where
we can not be considered as a school worker anymore
uh. Uh. Below.
And this salary will be just below the baseline minimum.
Uh. There's gonna be a rice
or the baseline minimum salary
sponsored skill worker
from 26 to 38,000 to 6,228, 38,700.
And. And furthermore, um.
The uh. Family spouse, uh.
There's gonna be an increase in the minimum salary um.
From 18,600 To,
uh, 38,700. Uh,
the graduate visa. Uh, uh,
this. The two years, uh,
that there's gonna be recommendation, uh,
by the migration and Vice Committee to review this
as it's been abused. Um,
time, if timeline,
are we looking at? Next year?
In spring 2024. Thank you.